tomorrow marks 100 days since the
assault on the capitol
and new numbers from the justice
department show that more than 400
suspects have been arrested from at
least 45
different states we're also getting our
first look at a report showing how
unprepared capitol police were that day
and our senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge is on
capitol hill for us
where the inspector general behind that
report will testify later today
catherine good morning to you
well tony good morning cbs news obtained
the watchdog findings that reveal
capitol police officers did not know
ahead of time
just how serious the threat was on
january 6 and they were blocked from
using aggressive crowd control tactics
three days before the violence an
intelligence assessment by the capitol
police
warned january 6 would be different
the targets of pro-trump supporters are
not necessarily the counter-protesters
but rather congress itself
on the day of the attack a conflicting
assessment said
violence was improbable an
internal defense department timeline
obtained by cbs news
also reveals new details of a dramatic
call
between former vice president pence and
then acting secretary of defense
chris miller from a safe location inside
the capitol
pence reported building not secure what
is the timeline
fbi must clear he was very in control
miller recently spoke with cbs news as
part of a national security panel
discussion
and he was focused on clearing the
capital and making sure that
that was done that day so that they
could get back to doing the people's
business
we all brought up the possibility that
for a need for extra security
cash patel miller's chief of staff was
on those january 6 calls
and also with miller three days earlier
when they met with then
president trump the president
preemptively gave us
the authority to deploy the national
guard as the secretary saw fit
the defense department memo says pence
pushed miller
and mark milley the chairman of the
joint chiefs on why
more national guard troops were not
provided in advance
on january 4 the memo states capitol
police confirmed
no requirement for military support d.c
mayor muriel bowser wanted a limited
guard presence for traffic control
but an hour into the riot at 1 49 p.m
an urgent call pleading for help came
from capitol police chief
steven sund to the d.c national guard
the approval for chief son's request
would eventually come
from the acting secretary of defense and
be relayed to me
by army senior leaders at 508 pm
about 3 hours and 19 minutes later did
the pentagon team slow roll the guard no
you can't just send in thousands of
uniformed military officers because they
say
deploy the national guard you have to
have a strategic plan
with local law enforcement and cbs news
has also obtained the raw intelligence
report from the fbi
that warned of violence the night before
the attacks that never made it to
leadership it contained
multiple threats this week senior law
enforcement and intelligence officials
testified to congress
that domestic extremism is among the
greatest threats
facing the u.s anthony catherine thank
you
still so many questions here about how
this was all allowed to happen
hindsight is always 20 20 but it seemed
like foresight was pretty 2020 also
yeah i mean how did you not anticipate
the possibility of this
and every time you look at the video it
just takes my breath away about what
happened you noticed something new every
time
exactly right tony and none of it good
no
none of it good